foreign
how arrogant are you
press a shot
how arrogant are you to think that you
deserve to go through life with no one
ever saying anything that you don't
agree with or like
so TK sent this to me and Ryan last week
and I said this would be a perfect talk
aboutable if you're just listening to
the audio version of this it's just a
video of Ricky Gervais and it's really
what is this video even about TK
it's about the phenomenon of being
offended I am offended by that joke you
just made and this is a comedian talking
about the efforts to censor comedians or
cancel comedians or shut down their
careers because someone is offended by a
joke they made which is a definite
development right because comedy uh is
probably becoming increasingly more safe
increasingly more delicate increasingly
more uh diplomatic and PC because many
comedians many people period are just
afraid to say what they really think or
afraid to say something that they
consider to be funny because someone's
going to say I'm offended and that might
be all it takes to bring about an end to
their career and what he's saying here
is that
it's arrogant to think that who that no
matter who you are you can go through
life and not have to deal with the fact
that there are people who will disagree
with you or see the world in ways that
are offensive to you that's a part of
life and some of the responsibility
belongs to us to come up with a robust
healthy mechanism for how we are going
to deal with the fact that
we are offended by things that other
people believe because you can't erase
that and you can't pass any kind of law
or policy that magically transforms
people's hearts and causes them to think
of us or feel about us in the way that
we want them to think and feel yeah
yeah I mean for me anytime I get
offended
um
my knee-jerk reaction is not to be like
oh you can't say that or you can't do
that and I'm offended and let me let me
project all of this you know offense
that I'm feeling it's more about
you know my knee-jerk reaction being
um why does this offend me
like is this something that
I need to be offended over and a lot of
times
um
you know it Roots back to you know
somewhere in my upbringing where
something happened and there's like a
wound there that
um is you know having salt poured into
or being reopened or whatever it is but
like it's sensitive and instead of me
saying oh well I have a wound there
don't touch that it's more about like
how can I heal that wound how can I you
know
um how can I toughen up I'm being mad
I'm just kidding no no but I mean it is
interesting I love the whole uh just
because you're offended doesn't mean
you're right saying yeah because because
really where you know where is it going
to be more valuable to just cancel
people anytime one person gets offended
or is it going to be more valuable to
like look at that person that's offended
and say you know hey why are you
offended is there a wound there that
maybe maybe needs healing and how can
you heal that wound yes it's almost like
um as a kid
you know the whole saying like sticks
and stones may break my bones but you
know names will never hurt me and
I mean that's that applies as adults too
yeah you know in fact the obverse of
that is also true and so yes people
don't have the power to offend you
unless you allow yourself to be offended
right but then also the compliments
aren't necessarily just because you're
offended doesn't mean it's true or just
because you're complimented also doesn't
mean it's true yeah I think that being
offended is
kind of a religious practice for many
it's a path of righteousness if you will
when I say I'm offended like if you make
a joke about Ryan and I say I'm offended
on behalf of Ryan it's hard for me to
not look like a good guy when I say that
it's very difficult for me to not seem
righteous and even though I've made no
arguments for my position even though I
haven't proven that what you have done
is wrong at the level of perception you
make a joke about Ryan and I say that
I'm offended on his behalf I look way
more righteous than you right without
having even earned it simply by having a
certain kind of emotional response and
the tricky part of that is
I take the risk of actually being
offensive to Ryan
by presuming that I can speak on behalf
of his concerns what if he finds it
funny and I'm offended on his behalf oh
what then and so many times when we put
our necks out there to be offended on
behalf of other people
we can do it out of a desire to be seen
as a righteous I'm a defender of these
people over here but have you taken the
time to talk to these people first
because there's a big difference between
being a voice for people who do feel
offended but are too afraid or powerless
to speak for themselves and being a
presumptuous person who in an act of
self-righteousness and virtue signaling
says I'm going to declare myself to be
offended on behalf of this group of
people that I would never go around
because I don't like the way they look I
don't like the way they smell I'm scared
to go through their neighborhoods but
I'm offended designate me as the
righteous one nah you gotta earn that
you got to earn that righteousness and
uh
it's possible that you might be correct
when you say I'm offended but we need
more evidence than just that
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free